[Musique]
lorsque vous acceptez le deal vous
subvenez au besoin de votre famille
pendant 20 ans
[Musique]
bien à vous
en sachant que vous n'avez pas pris plus
que votre part
le deal est un cadeau recevez-le
il a un ordre à suivre si tu veux
survivre
dehors il y a rien à découvrir au-delà
de ces murs tout a été bombardé
empoisonné ou a fini par cramer vivre
ici ça a rien de terrible mais au moins
on est tous envie merci pour votre
travail et à nouveau félicitations pour
votre intervention je vais accepter le
deal tu l'as fait tu l'accepteras pas
retardement il me l'aurait planté et
maintenant elle est en moi
[Musique]
c'est du temps on peut peut-être trouver
une solution
[Musique]
c'est ma fille je ne partirai pas tant
que je ne serai pas s'il va bien je vais
dans un endroit où le bureau n'a pas la
moindre autorité
c'est notre tick et de sous notre
dernier espoir
je vous conduis là-bas mais rien nous
assure qu'on vous acceptera on prend le
risque
on doit mourir pour avoir 20 ans de
ration de nourriture et eux ils vivent
comme ça à chacun sa façon de survivre
[Musique]
sois prudente dehors
tu as plus que 5 jours devant toi
tu es une seule chance de sauver ma mère
tu dois tout de suite me le dire
en
différent tu dois accepter le titre
êtes-vous prêt à mourir